good morning guys it's uh nice to see a
jam-packed room but it's a small one
nevertheless the story doesn't change
it's exactly the same story I'm going to
tell you guys uh before I get into this
topic I want to ask you a few questions
are any of you working already in
predictive medicines
now
are any of course my team of course with
us work on predictive entrance I can
imagine that
very good now let's say uh before
jumping into predictive maintenance you
also need to understand a bit of asml so
let's start a bit slowly with asml what
we do at asml and why predict tomato
doesn't say tough thing in general and
asml it becomes even tougher and what do
we have in place today so it's not only
about predictor marathons it is also
about sustaining predictive maintenance
at asml for for long term
let's see if this works
introduction to asml a very simple thing
what we do is we make machines to print
chips that's all what we do uh and even
simpler the technique what we use is uh
even much simpler is there is a pattern
on a mask we need to take this to a
wafer that's the most
basic fundamental thing we do at asms
the problem comes when uh when you have
this machine or yeah I call it a machine
it's not anymore a phone because of the
reason when you start looking inside it
this is the A8 chip from from many years
ago if you start zooming in
you'll realize what is happening inside
a chip
if you are now you are at micro meter
level
you are going deeper and deeper you are
looking at a city with roads with many
different constructions it's
three-dimensional you can see these are
all uh the Silicon layers you have a
complete construction is much more
beautiful than what you see in New York
it is much cleaner definitely than New
York so you can see that the dimensions
which we are dealing with is 15
nanometers now that is our critical
Dimension and our overlay is four
nanometers so you cannot make a mistake
more than four nanometers then things
doesn't work and the future size which
we are talking about is 15 nanometers
this is the feature which you are
talking this is Imaging uh purely what
we do this is the hardware uh printing
what we do in ASMR now
again now zoom out a bit started in
1984. uh now almost 2023 at this time
when we started Imaging with our first
past 2000
the resolution was micrometer level it
was our hair is around 50 microns the
resolution was around one or two
micrometers here now we are talking
about 14 nanometers 13.5 nanometers so
that's the Improvement that went through
the Imaging that means that that little
machine over there has become pretty
complex I will show you in a minute how
complex this machine is and where are
these machines used in a holistic
landscape this is your wafer
not your wafer at that point this is
your phone now before the phone comes
out you have to go through a series of
steps that's just pure silicon wafer it
goes through several steps and then
enters our machine once it enters our
machine there is a Imaging done as I
showed you the first features are set in
then there is a yield star which is also
our machine which does the control
inspection how good the overlay is and
then uh if things are okay things will
go to the next step sometimes we have to
Loop through many times before the wafer
is finished it takes roughly around two
to three months before the final chip is
ready this is not our work we only make
these machines but this is all done in
the Fabs now this is also the eelstar it
is after inspection everything is done
is everything is okay and then finally
there is a HMI machine also part of asml
now which is looking into how many
defects are there what is the yield so
this Zoo here this this is what asml
products are and these machines are
supposed to function at the best physics
that is put into them there is we need
to guarantee that this performance is
around the clock 24x7 around the year if
there is a mistake the
chips are not working then the final ill
is not okay then it's going to impact
Big Time throughout the rest of the
world or let's say there will be impact
for our end customers which we don't
want now how do we make sure that
everything runs well let's understand
then one more time at our latest UV
machine if you look at the latest we
mentioned the NXT machine it's roughly
around
180 000 kilograms this is a Boeing 747
it also weighs exactly the same we need
three of them to ship one machine to the
customer side uh somebody likes Mini
Coopers so in terms of 140 milligoupas
20 years of r d was put into it uh and
then there are interesting parties
somewhere around 15 000 sensors are
there so that means that it is a
streaming 4.5 terabits per day it's a
lot of data so when you get data what do
you do you have this data science
Community you think of
products that you can build on the top
of this data that's exactly what this
talk about so use this data to start
predicting the uh performance and the
maintenance that might be required for
this machine so that it always performs
at its best
now uh just a small advertisement we are
always actively by data community and
also at the ecml we have been organizing
quite a few uh workshops at ecml as well
so next time in addition to Pi data you
can also meet us at ecml as well
now a bit more about the landscape of a
data sensor to SNL uh I only told you
about what we do with respect to the
machines huh it starts already with the
supply chain you can also think about
supply chain analytics and in the
factory when we are assembling our
products and integrating and testing
there are also opportunities like
Factory Diagnostics and this is during
the Fab during the semiconductive
manufacturing this is where predictive
maintenance Falls there is also defect
detection and root cause analysis
performance optimization and also
surrogate modeling where we also use
machine learning algorithm in all these
things the one of the main data science
challenges High dimensional the the data
is high dimensional
it's also physically complex problems we
want to model physically complex
problems and
the models which we build needs to be
interpretable that's also a challenge
for us you can't just build a black box
model because your domain export or your
Fab engineer need to understand this
model at a great level so that they can
use them
uh lastly one more uh a few more things
about the machine then I will zoom into
the data science part
hi I'm Richard and I'm going to tell you
about the most important tech company
you've never heard of the name of the
company is ASMR and they make machines
that are used to create microchips I'll
share three striking facts about these
machines all in the next few seconds
which brings me to the first fact asml
machines generate extreme ultraviolet
light by hitting a multi-tin droplet 50
000 times per seconds twice with a laser
beam and that's hot hot hot
in fact the plasma that's generated is
hotter than the surface of the sun which
is 5500 degrees Celsius chips keep
getting smaller and faster thanks to
asml the most advanced chips easily top
100 million transistors per square
millimeter the structure on these chips
are just a few nanometers in size just
as a comparison a human hair has a
diameter of 90 000 nanometer that's
mind-blowing right
[Music]
so to put it in perspective again this
this is really very sophisticated
machine so predictments in general is
challenging this is my opening statement
now you want to do pretty maintenance
for these machines now so the challenge
starts here let me go into uh okay
slides are a bit corrupted that's not a
problem uh a bit of landscape uh what do
where does predict maintenance come
within the asml perspective this is the
time
and this is what the probability of a
maintenance it might the maintenance
might be needed for many different
reasons but let's look at in this
perspective when the machine is shipped
to the customer side the machine is
assembled it's rammed up it is it is
producing
Wafers this is what our end customers or
we also want the machine to be our
machine is built with lots of feedback
loops I already thought of many many
different scenarios they are very strong
at certain point feedback loops
triggering if there is degradation and
there is the first uh performance impact
it could be anything there could be a
first performance impact under certain
point uh very rare but this happens that
the equipment goes down but these are
really really rare events right now this
is where the impact happens and then we
know at the asml whenever this happens
we know how to deal with them we have to
bring the part bring the engineer and
then bring the system back to production
now the business opportunity for
predictive maintenance is here to know
in advance what is going to come ahead
of us not only the performance but also
the equipment
Diagnostics situations what might be
needed so why do we do that of course we
want to reduce the unplanned downtime at
the customer and we also want to prevent
that escalations we have many many smart
Engineers but it's never sufficient
because when there is an escalation we
have to uh
start working on it because we need to
bring the measure back to production if
you know in advance we can prevent some
of these things
now how do we do that this is something
I want to hand it over to our data
scientists how do we start doing machine
learning at asml I will come back to you
in a minute
thanks Sanjay
yeah uh so when it comes to the machine
learning and data science we earned our
knowledge from Active Learning with
human expert in the loop
uh we at dsne data science and
engineering have a very close
collaboration with various domain
experts from very any step of modeling
from data labeling to model training to
model evaluation but how it works is
something like that that the old data
the historical data are collected
the dominant expert together with data
scientists study this data very
precisely to understand about the status
of the of the machine and then the data
scientist will train a machine learning
by this historical data of course there
are a lot of challenges when we want to
train the model we have to tackle and
then when a new machine a new data from
new machine is coming this train model
should help us to understand if the
status of the machine is about to to
maintenance to need a maintenance or not
and to close this Loop we need to test
and validate the performance of this
model again with dominant expert and
also together with data scientists so
this is a continuous learning Loop and
it will go it will get several times
until the time that we are confident
that we this model is ready for
industrialization for the end user
um to a little bit show you how visually
visually show you that how it works I
want to or we want to show you a video
but before that uh let's see what we
want to to watch after after some
seconds
in the right side you see a green and
the red area which is about the status
of the machine red means that the
machine needs might need a maintenance
and green means that machine maybe
doesn't doesn't need for any maintenance
and in the right in the right side you
see the component the component one
which is representing the red area and
component 2 which is representing the
green area and they will show you the
risk probability of either of either red
or green area so now I want to pause for
a video I will leave you for a second to
watch this video and then I will come
back to that if it works yes
okay so maybe one more time if we can
pose
so this is about the live data the
orange one is a live data it's a new
data that is coming from new machine and
we see that is going through the red
area which means that the machine might
need the the maintenance at the same
time the risk probability also is going
up the risk probability of these orange
um sorry red area is increasing which
means again maybe the machine needs for
the maintenance if we are in that status
then the local CS have to have to help
for the maintenance and fortunately the
customer would be happy with this action
um
of course after after all of these phase
we need to validate and test the
performance of the model and also we
need to study what model wants to
explain we use a lot of metrics a lot of
criteria to validate this performance
for Simplicity we are just showing you
the confusion Matrix which is simply
about comparison between the predicted
labels which is coming from terrain
model and the true labels but of course
it's not just about the numbers we again
validate these numbers from confusion
Matrix or any metric again with dominant
expert and to make sure that this is
actually act correct current correct
numbers
another important part is the feature
importance so we want to we want to tell
the customer or the end user that and
which feature which parameters of your
of your machine for the specific failure
mode is um is having the most uh
contribution to predict something
whether you need to to do the
maintenance or not instead of just
looking a bunch of parameters we can
just tell them that which one is more
important so this is the whole story or
short story about the data science part
thanks sir Maybe
so I'm let's say I have quite a good
data scientist we have been already
developing models since a while we build
these models but there were other
challenges one of the big challenges was
uh
about uh bringing this model to the
market this is where a big challenge was
I will tell you what this is in a bit so
as hamita explained this is let's say a
predictive maintenance model it goes to
several steps there is data and then
there is a domain knowledge coming
through the labels feature engineering
feature selection model element and
installation we figured out that we do
these things very well this is a story
also from some time back so some of the
gaps which we have closed so when the
once the model is in the sliced this is
used by a field service engineer where
he is looking at a dashboard where he
get as a function of time he gets a risk
probability for each component now he
gets the risk probability whenever it
goes a certain uh whenever it costs 0.5
or whenever he has a traffic light he
start digging into it and then he takes
action in the right time he can prevent
it down for example here this was just a
test case where there was a component
was had needed a replacement where the
model could predict well in advance so
the domain exports were very happy hey
nice we could teach a stupid robot how
we think on a day-to-day basis so they
were very happy that they have more
students and they could teach more of
them to be further fine-tuned now the
challenge was it used to take a really
really long time to Industry to do from
here to here where uh there is value
created for asml it's it's a it's great
that we build data science models we
also need to bring it to the market this
is where the biggest challenge was so we
were thinking how can we solve this
problem uh we were wondering we were
looking into each of the different phase
there is a feasibility phase there is a
POC phase validation phase and
installation phase where are we losing
time well where where could we improve
and then we figured out we were losing
time in almost all the places and we had
to see what are the subtopics where we
are losing time there were challenges at
the data quality there were challenges
we we were doing a lot of manual work
and we were also using multiple
platforms to develop and initialize our
models so data quality acquisition of
the labels starting from there if you
have few domain exports there are
inconsistencies between the domain
exports and how the labels have been
given that might also be some
inconsistencies there starting there and
then the manual work like
bookkeeping what data is labeled what
data is not labeled where is the code
how is it checked in how are we testing
the models functional testing how are we
adapting these models if there are new
use cases coming in and then having two
platforms it's also redundant effort uh
to maintain two different platforms one
maintained by IIT one maintained by us
for development and having different
competencies uh between the uh between
the development team and the engineering
team so then we started looking around
and then we asked people hey guys do you
know what is the solution and then one
of the solution is mlops is a solution
this is what Google is using this is
what Amazon is using so we have to
embrace something new and then what is
this new part uh mlops is let's say
somewhere standing in between the
machine learning devops principles and
data engineering principle the idea is
we want to streamline the process of
taking machine learning models to
production so everything has to be
improved at each and every step and we
our way of thinking our uh regular uh
way of work has changed so from manual
labeling on Excel sheets or manual
labeling in PowerPoints we went to Smart
labeling started using some smart
leveling tools and then automation uh
the we used started using the devops
practices for example cicd where most of
the tests are done inside and then we
also have one single unified platform
once the model is developed there is no
need to put another wrapper around it
because it's already sitting inside a
nice container it can be deployed easily
so it enabled the most important part
for bringing any machine learning model
to production the fast iteration uh you
need you need to build a model and you
need to check if it is useful or not we
can do now with this fast iteration if
it is there is a problem we can fix it
and then we improve almost eight times
our time to Market uh we let's say it
took a month and then we went to wix
now I will describe a bit more about
what the solution which we have in place
today uh with a very high level uh
architecture which reduced our time to
in acceleration uh let's start with our
customers who are our customers our
customers are uh within asml it is a CS
customer support and also development
and Engineering teams and also other
data consumers this could also be
outside asml or somewhere internally
asml so ins there are there is only one
single platform but it is divided into
two pieces for many different reasons
there is a development part and there is
in resolution part exactly same copies
but the authorizations who can access
different pieces are different the first
part is integration uh three
fundamentals right you need the data you
need the methods and then you need the
knowledge uh you can't build blind
machine learning models in asml you
really need to understand the data to
the code before you start building the
models so we really need to integrate
the functional knowledge existing at
asml now once you combine all these
things you have the first data set
that's a labeled data set
previously from here we used to go
already do the modeling now we started
changing it there is a label inspection
tool automatic label inspection tool
that says hey domain export there are
certain inconsistencies do you want to
look back at it or we pop up if he
labels one machine there is a similar
machine with a similar
Behavior do you want to also label this
now that helps to go in these Loops
faster than converge to the right
accurate labeled data set and then you
can continue the remaining steps to do
the feature engineering and do the model
development on the most important part
the validation at this point you can say
my model is good you can stop at this
point because we have a good handshake
with cs or we need to go back or we need
to further go back here but these are
all let's say closed Loops the
everything has to uh everything is
already in place you should be able to
request the right person to do the right
thing and then everything comes in place
in a short period of time now now with
the click of a button the model is ready
and you do you you push it goes to the
CI CD and then the pipeline is deployed
in the in the production phase
where there is a single pipeline for
each failure mode uh the pipeline is
working trying to predict whether a
specific failure mode is going to appear
in the next few months or not and then
the output is consumed by the uh our
consumers consumers when they consume
they always have feedback this is a
something very nice right this is in the
beginning I was wondering too much
feedback might mean that we only will be
integrating the feedback but the fact
that the feedback started coming in
faster you can actually improve your
models much faster
so there is customer feedback once the
customer feedback comes in what you can
do is you can monitor how good your
model is behaving today is the model
behaving as expected or is there some
performance issues once you know how
good your model is behaving because here
you have an expectation you transfer it
to production
now it gives the real beta test value if
you have a prison and a recall of 1990
here it you could already see probably
the recall has dropped to 70 or
something like that now what can you do
if you have a continuous training
pipeline in place The Continuous
training pipeline will automatically
trigger and deploy the new model so that
you don't have to worry about it if it
is just a small data drift issue that
will be fixed sometimes it can be
possible that that's not sufficient you
have to go all the way back to redo this
but many of these things are in place so
basically the problem has changed or the
component has changed so much you have
to relabel the data and you have to redo
this whole process this is what we call
the mlops solution that we have placed
at the asml where from end to end
everything is now let's say automated we
are using the new ml Ops principles and
this saved us a lot of time in addition
to that there's a pipeline monitoring
this is exactly useful for me to see on
my control room to see hey guys there is
a pipeline that is red that means that
one of our customers is not seeing the
results as expected so I we can also
immediately figure out what is happening
there and our IIT teams can help us
bring the pipeline back to production
through this uh by mindset change and
also the way of working change we went
uh from let's say uh months to weeks to
build a solution and to productize it
now let's say the Machinery some of you
might be very interested in what is the
Machinery behind uh the we have behind
this architectural picture of course we
are in Google uh Google Cloud platform
we use a platform uh we use uh data proc
for for our uh spark Pipelines
and Cloud Source reports where our code
is stored and we are of course using
container registry where our containers
have stole a cloud build for our cicd
part this is also something interesting
maybe some of you might not know we
always try to reuse whatever we built
that also helps us not to build
everything from scratch so we have a
internal solution called a d box where
we put our reusable blocks so every data
scientist whenever he builds up
something the others can use the same
script or the same function uh so that
they don't have to start from scratch
now uh there as you see here again here
the the AI pipelines here is no
different from the other one it's
basically the same pipelines that will
help move from platform a to platform b
as soon as possible and run it there
so the this is let's say uh one of the
last slide I have the the I told you
about the uh training pipelines or the
continuous training pipeline uh it's
hard to see it's highly pixelated for
the purpose that you don't read it uh
as you can see this is in a place uh so
what it does is basically uh Whenever
there is a training needed uh for for a
specific machine uh it goes to the
training uh pipeline so there are
multiple scenarios that are
I wouldn't call it auto ml but there are
multiple machine learning algorithms we
would like to try it out with multiple
hyper parameters and we spit out the
best model and then we would like to use
those best models uh in the prediction
pipeline the pipeline that is for a
specific failure mode it is predicted in
the output which will be published
towards the dashboards where the output
will be used by our field service
engineers now uh you might be wondering
how did we transition this might be also
something interesting for some of you
when we started using our laptops a few
years back we started building our
models in our laptop using Jupiter
notebook and then we were trying to
deploy in our high performance Computing
Center it used to take let's say x
amount of time when we learned about ml
Ops we of course didn't go directly to
it we want to test out the waters right
we started moving mL of 0 envelope zero
plus now envelopes one plus you could
see uh whatever it was X it came down
significantly down this is really weeks
now to uh from the intake of a specific
use case or a specific failure mode we
understand it build a model and
initialize it now we are talking about
sustainable productive maintenance if it
really takes months or weeks because
asml is also evolving so fast the the
product itself can change before you
build a model so it is really important
that we build models and industrialize
in time so that the value is delivered
at asml
now uh a conclusioner I think let's say
many of you might be working on machine
learning products uh never ever
try to succeed in the first attempt
you need to iterate iteration is key and
first iteration is key to success
industrialization of models is also
important keep that in mind always for
us it works by embracing envelopes
methodology we could go from months to
weeks here uh specifically let's say for
us this is also within asml
advertisement
we started building only a couple of
models now we are more than tens of
models that are in production uh being
used uh our customers are happy we are
still counting on uh with this new thing
in place we are let's say looking into
the future uh to receive more requests
to build more predictive maintenance
models
this is a slide I will play in a bit but
if you have questions now I will take it
thanks I saw a hand over there yeah
thank you
because
like across all your machines or do you
have to train them separately for
different customers
they don't want information about how
it's leaking out
yeah I have to repeat the question for
the online audience if there are any or
future ones maybe
do we train models centrally or do we
adopt the models locally to protect the
customer information
uh very good question we do both
uh depending upon uh what we are talking
about what failure more and what is the
model going to do uh what data we use
there are certain models where we can
use asml specific knowledge which can be
built here when we have to use a
customer specific knowledge we built at
the customer site and deploy it with
customer site both are true yeah
good question
go ahead
website though
is that they can also get stuck in a
local Optimum because the model believes
that the world Works a certain way
um so you've got that little conflict
between what the model thinks and
reality is that a concern for your
machines as well
yeah
yeah
I I think you are absolutely right if it
is uh it can
we we have it in place
to some extent to help our domain expert
but it can also really annoy them to
continuously
pop something that is not okay
uh
so
it is a bit of pragmatic approach there
uh when you know
things are not working you want to
interfere so the active learning
approach there is algorithm that always
spits out but you can also immediately
cross check if it is really
suggesting the right suggestion or not
this is when the data scientists
generally interfere
on the help out but your observative
right it can sometimes instead of
helping it can also cause damage to the
original purpose on a day-to-day basis
uh I cannot tell on what percentage it
is
generally the data scientists sit with
the domain export and then try to
explain the results
it already helps to look at them
together
and then read the readings if the data
scientists observed that the let's say
the pop-up by the active learning
algorithm is not okay he has to meddle
with the algorithm
foreign
do we have one model for all the
landscape or do we have separate models
for each different product
this is a very good question and the
yeah
yeah I I cannot be completely honest
here because this is IP protected
but let me see uh the answer is uh
there are universalities when you look
at the component level
uh you want to maximize this
universality so this is where
understanding that component and that
data helps a lot
and when you look at this data you make
choices uh Do you want to build
uh one model across the fleet is it the
functionality is the same but in some
cases it might not be the case that is
when you want to think of certain
hierarchical modeling kind of situations
yeah so there's a brief answer for your
nice question
natural learning to make it faster to
portraying this new failure yeah very
very good question do we use a transfer
learning to adapt from failure mode a to
we do it a lot uh in in two different
ways uh transfer learning in the model
and also with the data scientists and
also in the uh with the experts as well
so there are components which are very
close uh the functionality is similar
especially with the product Evolution
the uh when you go to a different
product the model which you have built
for this product and then when it is uh
adapted in the new product
you probably don't have enough data
there so you can't you can start from
scratch but the quality of model you can
already guess it might not be the same
this is when you can already take the
models which you have built today and
adapted to the feature use cases through
transfer learning yes we do use those
Concepts yes
yes then let me play the video uh can
you help me play the video because
this is also something some of you some
it might be interesting for some of you
you get to say that you're working with
some of the most advanced machines in
the world
you see people from different countries
that's what I also enjoy
it's fun that you can do something with
a large group of people outside of work
[Music]
problem solving is my job there is a
mechanical problem and I have to solve
it by Design
[Music]
foreign
engineer so I'm integrating the system
and installing it at the customer site
this is our football team we're gonna
compete in a competition in China in the
summer so it's really exciting
I moved over to Holland on my own so I
didn't know anybody
but this is a great way to meet people
that have the same interests as you
every day is just learning something new
always pushing the boundaries of your
imagination you never thought you'd be
doing something so high-tech
[Music]
I'm a Imaging applications engineer I
basically test the performance of the
machine before we ship it to the
customers the place where I come from
India is a very small town I did my PhD
at the University of 20. after that I
joined asml ASM is always open to give
chances to meet different cultures I'm a
mechanical designer my task is to design
build up and test the tooling for our
latest UV machines during my work I
think a lot I design with my head or
starts up here
to keep my head clear I really need to
be active so this helps me to focus and
gives me a lot of pleasure and
satisfaction
I'm a flex worker here with an asml I
work via external company but still I
feel like being part of asml
for the immersion project specifically
the immersion Hood I make sure that the
component actually works in the machine
and works together with the other
technology that's also there when you
talk to other departments and you see
what their problems are you see what
they are dealing with struggling with
you also learn a bit about them that's I
think the most challenging part for me
the most fun part I'm involved in an
organization called young asml I
organize a trip to Zeiss Zeiss is the
supplier of our optic equipment so we
organize the trip with 50 people there
and we we went for a visit it was really
cool
I'm on my way to skip all the airports
flying to South Korea to Samsung I'm
installing machine over there one of
asml's leading products my job is so
cool and I get to travel so it's amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so it was the reason why I played this I
still have open positions in my team
uh and also data science is a quite
active growing community in asml and
there are roughly let's say a hundred
core uh or slightly more than 100 core
data science data engineers and machine
learning Engineers there are quite a few
citizen data scientists in this
community is quite vibrant now we are
part of a data Department within asml
you can definitely look out for the open
versions We have and it is cool to work
at asml join us if you are interested
[Applause]
foreign
thanks everyone that was it so if you
want to run a marathon or wear a funny
hat uh hit up these guys about asml
thank you and feel free to move on to
your next sessions now